hola qué tal según el consejo nacional
electoral fueron admitidas tres
solicitudes de revocatorio contra
nicolás maduro entre ellas está el
movimiento venezolano por el revocatorio
mover este estar integrado por nicmer
evans que es disidente del chavismo por
el ex gobernador césar pérez vivas y
también por un ex diputado nelson chiki
entre otros hasta el momento ese es de
los que más ha tenido pronunciamientos a
través de medios de comunicación y redes
sociales de hecho ya lo han calificado
como una pequeña victoria pero que debe
ser administrada según palabras de
nicmer evans pues saben que el proceso
es aún más largo falta como le decía es
la recolección del 20 por ciento de las
firmas de los inscritos en el consejo en
el consejo nacional en el registro
electoral pero además basta saber cuáles
son otras condiciones que impondrá el
ente electoral
los otros dos movimientos todos unidos
por el referendo revocatorio y comité
ejecutivo nacional de cofe de junta
realmente no son no están integrados por
personas reconocidas a través de medios
de comunicación hay individualidades que
han solicitado ante el consejo nacional
electoral este revocatorio y según lo
que pudimos conocer por
hace algunas semanas por juan guaidó es
que hasta el momento no ha habido algún
pronunciamiento por parte
respecto a esta solicitud quien decía
que era una decisión que se tenía que
tomar de toda la oposición en caso de
que fueran a elegir esta vía para para
que haya un cambio de gobierno en
venezuela y que al momento no iba a
haber algún pronunciamiento sobre esto y
que en una decisión que se tenía que
tomar en conjunto daniela brevemente
cuáles son los argumentos de las
asociaciones que presentaron estas
peticiones para iniciar el trámite de
referéndum
bueno el principal argumento es que ya
se cumplió la mitad del mandato de
nicolas maduro y por eso es un derecho
constitucional que se puede solicitar
que se revoque el mandato sin embargo
está el antecedente del año 2016 cuando
la oposición a través de la mesa en la
unidad democrática solicitó al consejo
nacional electoral un referendo
revocatorio recolectó la firma pero
fueron cambiadas las condiciones y
posteriormente se paralizó el proceso
luego que en tribunales se hiciera una
solicitud de anulación por considerar
que eran firmas fraudulentas en ese
momento que la oposición está unida y
que logró recolectar incluso más de las
firmas necesarias el cn paraliza el
proceso y luego no se volvió a reanudar
y es por eso que hay mucha desconfianza
por parte de los principales líderes de
la oposición en solicitar este mecanismo
y que no vuelva a suceder tal y como
sucedió en el 2016 que no se avanzó con
el proceso